hi I'm Erik Bosse in the newest x-men
movie Dark Phoenix has an official
trailer so yeah this movie is still
happening despite the Fox x-men
universes announced merger with the
Disney Marvel Universe but you know what
after seeing this trailer I think this
movie couldn't have been the perfect
swan song to be a different burden in a
song for the x-men brand before it gets
rebooted probably so I'm gonna break
down this trailer frame by frame for
some interesting details and Easter eggs
that you might have missed to explain
why we should look forward to seeing
this movie in February spoiler warning
in case I accidentally revealed too much
and let's get started you think you can
fix me gee you are not broken
this trailer opens with a young Jean
Grey arriving at the estate of Charles
Xavier sometime after the 70s events of
Days of Future past that's right we're
in the x-men universe now folks the
timeline to your crazy and as we'll see
in this trailer this movie seems to be
changing jeans mutant backstory from the
comics so G gray is an omega-level
mutant talking top level here people she
has advanced telepathy and telekinesis
and in the comics these powers manifest
when a friend of hers gets in a car
accident and jeans mind kind of links
with her friends causing Jean to go into
a coma as well and that's where this
cosmic Phoenix force discovers genes
consciousness and binds with it she
likes this young jeans potential if she
stays dormant within her that's why when
you watch x-men apocalypse well some of
you did a version of the Phoenix force
merges in a movie now this movie Dark
Phoenix is pulling from the Dark Phoenix
saga it's really one of the best x-men
storylines and those issues there's a
space mission that goes wrong and the
Dark Phoenix Returns to Jean Grey and
takes over and I assume we will see that
next level transition in this movie and
yes you may remember we did see a
version of this storyline and X been the
last stand but you know that movie
sucked and Days of Future past reset
that timeline because as I said the
Cinematic Universe timelines are crazy
and by the way the music we're hearing
here is the end by the doors it's a
cover of it and notice how the music
plays right over the Fox studios and
Marvel logos and yeah I do think this is
a meta not here as this will probably be
the end for the Fox Marvel brand of the
x-men before Kevin Feige takes over but
I also think this story will be an
interesting end in a different way but
you know we'll get to that later
let's move on behind there's a fragile
thing takes only the slightest tap to
tip it in the wrong direction
Charles what did you do I had to keep a
stable my protected in this section we
get this cool blink jump cut it happens
right after Charles's line about a
slightest tap sending the mine in the
wrong direction the editing here
reflects this idea a mere blink seems to
splinter genes perception from past to
present we also see that Charles has
apparently rebuilt cerebro sometime in
the 1990s when this story takes place
after it and the entire mansion was
blown up in the events of x-men
apocalypse
it is Hank McCoy analyzes gene and
probably sees that her mental activity
is off the charts weird Charles and
Raven debate him hiding something from
gene get more into that after the next
clip to the truth
there's another word for that okay here
we see what appears to be the new origin
for Jean Grey just a cajones style car
accident that kills her parents it looks
like jeans uncontrollable telekinesis
might have caused this fatal collision
you can actually see how she keeps the
broken shards of glass from hitting her
face my theory is that this traumatic
memory is what Charles kept from Jean
perhaps he used his telepathy to wipe
the memory from jeans mind hoping to
protect her from her own inner darkness
but also preventing her from
understanding herself and learning to
control that darkness when it returns
nice going Charles also let's talk about
the new blue and yellow x-men suits this
movie is really steering into that
classic color scheme with even simpler
stitching honestly I kind of like the
reimagined versions of those blue and
yellow suits at the end of Apocalypse me
now I get it it's good that people can
actually breathe in these suits let's
move on I came looking for answers
[Applause]
you feel like you don't belong here you
don't they can't begin to comprehend
what you are changing in this section we
see this island where magneto has said
of some kind of hippie colony this could
be Genosha it's an all mutant island
nation from the Marvel Comics that
magneto rules over I like this detail
that all the structures are metallic you
know you can see shipping crates the
hull of a boat
remember in Apocalypse magneto nearly
destroyed the planet by an earth day and
all the metal in the soil and also all
the pieces of metal and all the cities
and we actually saw these kind of
shipping crates and boats lifted from
the ocean floor so it's nice to see he
found a way to recycle all that stuff I
guess the UN is like you know please
just live here and leave us alone
and there's a black rainy umbrella you
know that means a funeral but more on
that in a bit
in next we see Jessica Chastain's
character now it's still unknown what
character she'll be playing but there
has been some speculation that she could
be the character named lilandra who's an
alien of the Shiar race the she rrrr
another alien empire from Marvel Comics
along with races like the Kree in the
scroll that we've started to learn more
about from Captain Marvel she our play a
big role in the Dark Phoenix storyline
intervening on Phoenix force Jean Grey's
warpath and it points putting her on
trial and depowering her now there has
been other speculation that Chastain
could be playing a female version of
x-men villains like mastermind or mr.
sinister but director Simon Kinberg has
denied those theories and instead
embraced the cosmic elements of the
backstory and we should point out the
official synopsis of this movie did
specifically mention aliens who wish to
weaponize the Phoenix force and rule the
galaxy so I think the Shiar would be the
best bet and after returning and
appearances of Scott Summers and Peter
Maxima or a Munroe and Hank McCoy we
move on to the next clip just changing
what you didn't come here looking for
answers you came here looking for
permission children
so as Charles and braven continue to
worry about Jean we now see Jean with
Erik Lehnsherr if you look closely at
our eyes you can see that some of that
Phoenix fire is starting to burn
it sounds like Jean was tired of good
daddy hiding her powers from her so she
ran away it's a bad daddy to get
permission to use them freely hmm you
know the internet really ruined daddy
for us and next we get a look at what I
think will be a very key moment in the
movie with a very interesting easter egg
so the x-men suit up and confront Jean
in this neighborhood where everything
goes wrong but the details are in the
background here behind Scott you can see
a bishop power truck which seems like a
possible nod to Bishop the mutant who
absorbs energy and releases it from his
body he's kind of a constant conductor
for radiation electricity so either this
truck is just a little nod to Bishop and
his powers or maybe Bishop is in this
universe running The Electric Company
applying his abilities to just an honest
day job but that's not even the really
cool Easter egg that I was referring to
look at the name of the town on the
police cars Red Hook
now Red Hook is a small town in New York
State but the reason that's important
here is it was mentioned in the show
legion legion is a series on FX you
should definitely check out it follows
David Haller and other omega-level
mutant who is technically part of this
x-men movie universe there are
references in the show to Patrick
Stewart Charles Xavier and Dark Phoenix
director Simon Kinberg is a producer on
the show so Red Hook was mentioned one
time in the very first episode of Legion
the old man overseen Division three
referred to a past incident where an
uncontrollable mutant did major damage
after what happened in Red Hook NJ
that's an understatement
and after that Red Hook was really just
left as a mysterious backstory that was
never revealed but now Dark Phoenix
appears to be filling in that gap
Division threes response to David holler
was a reaction to the Phoenix incident I
just loved that her putting this detail
in the movie movie now
[Music]
hey miss war coming out of us
Jean lost control if she's still upset
this is sure to hold Charles okay here
we see more of Jean in action crashing a
helicopter presumably full of soldiers
assaulting Magneto's hippie Connie it
looks as though these guys are sweeping
an old Metro car that Eric's hippies are
living in we also see some shots of that
space mission that they estimate go on
that leads to Jean coming back into
contact with the Phoenix the synopsis
has described this as a rescue mission
but we don't really know much else eeeh
in the comics deadly radiation from
solar flare nearly killed Jean but
really it's this moment that the Phoenix
entity attaches to her it takes over her
identity we also see some sad looking
members of the x-men and funeral attire
get mad at each other I have some
thoughts on that later let's move on but
well just on the break I'm sorry I
didn't stop it's you man you're always
sorry Charles
and there's always a speech and nobody
cares
they're still okay here we see the solar
flare that I was talking about as well
as Charles appearing to experience it
vicariously through cerebro perhaps he's
tapping into genes mind retracing her
memories to try to determine exactly
what happened to her Charles apologizes
and Herrick burns them with a good
nobody cares where your stupid speeches
which is especially sad when you
consider Charles's future apology speech
in his final moments I did sing
unspeakable yeah I guess no one was
really listening that neither and look
closely at Magneto's helmet in this
locker
underneath is an old newspaper and real
close you can see a headline mentioning
something about News cameras capture
Whitehouse I assume that is from the
incident in Days of Future past remember
when can I neither ripped out the
Whitehouse safe room to try to kill
Nixon in front of the news cameras but
of course it was actually mystique and
she proved him wrong ultimately that by
showing these news cameras that mutants
aren't monsters she really prevented a
terrible terrible future I think there's
a reason magneto keeps this newspaper
and a reason for that single tear but
I'll get to that after the next clip
don't do this
[Applause]
they're right to fear me
I've seen evil
okay here we see magneto with a new line
up we see that beast has joined his team
turning against Charles and two
newcomers to his immediate right is
Selene in the Marvel Comics Selene is a
mutant villain to the x-men she's
associated with the Hellfire Club she's
a sorceress and kind of a psychic
vampire who psionically drains other's
life forces and to her right is Red
Lotus martial arts master who started as
an x-men foe but then later join them
going undercover in the Hellfire Club
his role was actually teased and
Deadpool - in an Easter Egg at the
beginning of the movie Deadpool looked
at a business card with some Chinese
characters on it those are actually
Cantonese for Red Lotus also in the
section we see this overhead shot of a
funeral so someone definitely dies in
this movie see the end song did have
more than one meaning now I'm gonna go
to my theory for who kicks the bucket
but if you don't really want to know
skip to this time okay if you look
closely you can kind of figure this out
through the process of elimination in
these funeral shots you can see Hank and
Charles also storm and Nightcrawler
though you know you would think storm
wouldn't need an umbrella you know just
make an overdramatic speech and clear
those rain clouds storm come on
so this death is probably what turns
Hank against Charles so I think we can
assume that mutant faceoff shot to be
after the death in in those shots we can
see magneto and Scott Summers are also
alive and given that we P magneto shot I
think he's being brought back into the
fight due to the death of a character
who means a lot to him and to Hank and
really the only one left who went back
to x-men first class with these guys is
mystique yeah I think she did in fact
that may be what we're looking at and
it's close up at least embracing
mystique space I think Jean Grey loses
control of her Phoenix powers and
accidentally kills Raven and that is
what tears the x-men apart it would make
sense for Jennifer Lawrence to want to
leave the franchise at this point she
hates sitting in those makeup chairs and
she has been weirdly the face of the
past few x-men movies I know she's a big
star but it's just kind of weird when
there's a ton of other interesting x-men
characters and franchise besides
mystique so her character's death would
be a fitting conclusion to this line of
films and the way the Logan movie was an
emotional send-off to Hugh Jackman and
Patrick Stewart's take on the characters
looking back the Fox excellent movies
have been pretty good overall so they
deserve some kind of emotional cathartic
moment in their final chapter and before
I move on we get the clearest image yet
of Jean overtaking with the Phoenix
force perhaps Jean is getting sucked out
into space here and the Phoenix kicks in
going frame by frame through this some
of those fiery beams definitely have a
bird shape to them though I kind of see
Birds everywhere I run into door frames
a lot moving on to this last clip I'm
looking at it now
[Applause]
okay our last shot is of Jean Grey with
the spirit of the Phoenix overtaking her
the fire streaking through her cheeks in
her eyes and who just that evil stare it
makes it feel like a little finger huh
my question for you guys is considering
this will probably be the final Fox
x-men movie before things move over to
Marvel not including the New Mutants
which is kind of its own thing which of
these x-men characters would you want to
see cross over into the MCU as is
without getting recast and which
character should be rebooted personally
I've always loved bass bender as magneto
whatever they do at least keep that guy
around he's awesome comment down below
with your thoughts and follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at a boss and if
you love the x-men and live in the LA
area you know you've got to come check
out my live parody show called infinity
fan where we can laugh about how weird
it is when various x-men universes
collide trust me Deadpool takes care of
everything kind of show details and
ticket info are in the description below
and subscribe to new rock stars or more
deep dives into the stuff you love
thanks for watching bye